Beyond netro is Immortal but not in a
good way if indeed there is a good way
Beyond is an unknown quantity in most
respects someone known that even his
existence was shrouded from the hunter
Association despite the fact that he is
already at least a 70 year old man who
has been entrenched in global politics
for the last 50 years and given that
Beyond is now at least 70 if you're
wondering how old Isaac is the really
sad answer is that we don't know
conservatively speaking he was at least
110 years old when he died but that
number could easily be 150 200 300 or
even more he was an end master so he was
able to employ and conserve his life
force to live longer than normal humans
but also he went to the Dark Continent
and after returning Isaac nashro
experienced unnaturally long life even
for an end Master which has led many to
speculate that he found Nitra rice or a
similar life-extending substance on the
continent and his son Beyond did
something similar however his solution
was much more Sinister than just numbing
on delicious races bizarreling enough
Beyond was a key member of one of the
few recorded Dark Continent Expeditions
which occurred 50 years ago and was
undertaken by the kukanyu kingdom now if
you've never heard of that Kingdom just
don't worry I've got you covered this
kingdom was actually the Genesis of the
story because it was the site of the
287th hunter exam featuring all of your
favorites like gone kilua the the bedora
guy the killer killed and for some
reason in the 1999 anime only a girl
named Anita whose father was a drug
dealer yeah good times anyway the
kukanyu kingdom was a member of the V5
which means it was one of the top five
best Kingdom places so they had lots of
money lots of power and lots of
influence and deciding that they wanted
more of all three of those things they
invested in an Excursion to the Dark
Continent employing Beyond netro to lead
their expedition team this was because
by this time Beyond was somehow
recognized as one of the world's
foremost experts on Dark Continent
travel meaning that either this was not
Beyond's first expedition and that he
was some sort of notorious serial
Continental offender or it means that he
was just the most well-versed in all of
the available literature that and he
probably heard some stories from his
father who went at least twice maybe one
of those times was even with Beyond yeah
maybe I Isaac natural was such a
terrible father that he took his son to
the Dark Continent I I don't put it past
him also this video is sponsored by
Macarena The Game featuring teams of
giant robots Pew pewing each other into
Oblivion and what is not to love about
blowing stuff up with friends nothing
that's what nothing is to not not love
about what it's fun it's fun is what I
meant to say and it's just gotten even
more fun because world famous soccer
star Neymar Jr has stepped onto the
battlefield as a limited edition Mech
pilot that you can get for free just by
playing Neymar boost your damage from
missile and assault weapons plus he's
the only pilot in the game with a
special perk of longer and more often
mechs printing he is the strongest pilot
in the game and to get him you just need
to play Macarena on seven different days
between October 6 and December 18th plus
install Macarena on mobile and PC using
my personal link or QR code and you'll
get this restarter pack worth 15 an
amateur crate 308 coins and a pulse
Cannon Fort Kickstart your game and if
you're quick you can add me to your
friends as groundline guy and we can
play matches together on mobile or PC so
do that thing but for now it's back to
you me the main reason why Beyond was
hired was to circumvent the hunter
Association and the other V5 Nations who
if they'd known of the kukanyu Kingdom's
intentions would have made life very
very politically difficult now Beyond's
team was supposed to follow a previously
mapped route potentially from the book
written by Don Freaks and they were in
search of an Alchemy plant known as
Medallion which assumedly would have
revolutionized Humanity in some way
shape or form here's the thing though
they succeeded they actually succeeded I
mean at first anyway they managed to
secure The Medallion however at this
point the team went off Route and
encountered one of the five calamities
being so by and obviously it's a little
bit Mighty suspicious that they went off
Route and at this point I would like to
remind everyone that they were being led
by Beyond after which point almost
everyone in the Expedition dies The
Medallion plant died and only six
survivors returned to the human realm
four of which also does more dye
happening there than most DND games and
look I'd say this Expedition didn't go
well but two survivors is actually the
second best result from one of these
trips that we have ever recorded but
let's talk about quality of life for a
second because the two survivors were
Beyond natural and an unnamed
professional Hunter the latter of which
is currently kept in the world's most
secure prison science facility because
he is infected with zobai to touch on
that a bit more so Bai is known as the
immortality disease and some of you
probably already know where I'm going
with this you're all very clever but
just stick with me as a disease obai has
the officially designated threat rank of
b-plus meaning that the human world
considers this more of a problem than
they did the Chimera ants you know the
ones who are most eradicated all of
humanity those Chimera ants but so bye
is a very picky condition and despite
being named the immortality disease it
killed the vast majority of the people
it infected the unnamed Hunter who
returned from the dark continent is the
only official Survivor carrying zobai
which has since transformed him into
this Immortal zombie style thing
according to officials this Hunter is
quote no longer human and has been
self-sustaining for the last 50 years it
physically cannot die it just lingers on
and on and on being referred to as
endless despair disguised as hope the
question we now need to ask is how
Beyond netro avoided being infected with
zubai and the answer is that he almost
certainly didn't again zubai is very
demanding of its host those who aren't
strong enough to contain it die shortly
thereafter and those that are strong
enough never die no matter how lonely
they're after but they do lose their
sense of humanity and become more akin
to something of a wild animal that's
because that unnamed Hunter still wasn't
strong enough what would happen if so by
infected a world-class nen user someone
who is powerful enough not only to
contain it but also to incorporate it
into them rather than the other way
around that is what I propose happened
in the case of Beyond's netra and that's
why his most famous line in the series
is I'll wait as long as it takes because
time isn't a big problem to the person
with the immortality disease and again
he is already at least 70 years old and
that assumes that he was only 20 when he
was considered a global Dark Continent
expert he could be pushing 80 even 90s
maybe he's even gone the full Century by
now and if I was around that age I'm not
sure that I'd have the luxury of
patience to enact my master plans and
the hunter hunter world is no different
to reality in that regard non-nen users
have a very standard human lifespan and
even amongst net Masters we have very
few elderly examples to call on but
beyond with the immortality disease has
no such concern for time whenever it
happens that's great so long as it does
happen however in regards to the
happening there was one big problem
after the zobai Expedition Beyond's
father Isaac natural forbade Beyond from
traveling to the Dark Continent until
after his death which is well it's a
little problematic when your father has
also been to the Dark Continent and may
have also discovered a cure for
mortality Isaac naturo was not going to
die from natural causes at least not
anytime soon and he was one of if not
the most powerful human in all of the
hunting-based history so murdering him
isn't exactly an easy task and that's
why it took Beyond 50 years to
accomplish her being the rather
inquisitive lad he was I believe that
zobai was not the only Calamity that
Beyond uncovered my belief is that he
also found a chimera ant or ants plural
and like any good son going on a holiday
he brought his father home a valuable
souvenir if you want to know more about
this I have a video about how Beyond
embarristan engineered the Khmer parent
crisis as a plot to kill Isaac but for
the purposes of this video it's just
important to know that the ant Queen was
spliced with human DNA and dropped off
at just the right place at just the
right time to do all of the anti-stuff
but beyond had more to accomplish in the
next half century than simply breeding
deadly nenance because nedro's death
alone was not the only prerequisite to
his Dark Continent Journey what Beyond
also needed were the resources to
conduct it and also a bit of a sneaky
political loophole because another side
effect of Beyond's Journey was that
Isaac netro successfully convinced the
V5 to ban Dark Continent travel entirely
which was agreed upon in writing by all
Global Nations whether they were part of
the V5 or not so if the nation were to
do something like say break that
agreement then that that would be cause
for war that's okay though because
Beyond is a very very clever man he set
his sights on kakin Hui Guero which very
conveniently was a nation located on the
same continent as ngleniscorto where the
Chimera ant crisis would play out in
fact when gon and kill were first
encounter kite that is actually in the
nation of kakin in the 2011 anime kite
actually destroys a colony of chimera
and seeing kakin implying that they're
native they're just on a much smaller
scale almost as if someone introduced
the species and was conducting tests to
analyze their behavior but that's all
anime stuff that's that's not manga
Cannon what's more important is that 30
years ago kakin huigoro underwent a
political shift transforming from a
socialist empire into a parliamentary
democracy almost overnight in an event
dubbed the most silent revolution in
history and the thing is we don't know a
whole lot about what that Revolution
actually did the previous royalty of
kakin remained installed and the life of
the Everyday People was very much the
same as ever however what it did was
change the name of the Empire previously
it was called kakin huigoro but after
the revolution it was renamed simply to
kakin which meant that technically it
was a new country and thus not bound by
all of the former agreements made by the
country that it is now not so kakin are
free to go to the Dark Continent if they
so choose to and so I believe that
Beyond nestro orchestrated the silent
revolution in conjunction with either
king or Prince nasabi whichever he was
at the time Beyond Maeve even agreed to
back now Sabi during his own succession
war and ensure that he becomes the next
king of kakin in exchange for this very
minor technical country-changing request
and of course as time went on Beyond
convinced NASA be that going to the Dark
Continent that was a very good idea
because kakin would flourish and in fact
not only to go but to settle on the Dark
Continent so look it took three decades
but Beyond's patience paid off he now
had the resources and political means to
launch another Expedition there was just
one very Isaac natural shaped problem
remaining so everything I've said about
Beyond so far I think paintum is rather
Sinister the whole you know the plot to
murder your father singer that's pretty
bad but this is going to sound weird I
don't actually think it's as bad as it
sounds Beyond absolutely respected his
father to some degree considering that
he obeyed Isaac's decree of not
traveling until he was dead and also I
think that the methodology by which
Beyond may have chosen to kill his
father was nothing short of an act of
love this is the natural family we're
talking about they are far from your
average group of Gene sharers and the
bulk of Isaac natural his entire
existence was to seek a challenge to
find an opponent worthy of killing him
and go all out for the first and the
last time means istom even once posited
that he had hoped Beyond would be that
opponent someone strong enough to come
and kill him and in fact my personal
speculation is that Isaac set that death
condition to actively encourage Beyond
to take his life but beyond did end up
granting his father's ultimate Wish by
providing him with an Unstoppable and
King summing to complete Isaac notaro's
long and remarkable life in the meantime
Beyond also provided an entree in the
form of paristan to serve as Isaac's
Vice chairman a sort of interim opponent
to keep him entertained until the ants
were ready to be Unleashed in his own
Way Beyond was honoring his father
whilst also working towards his own
goals and that really changes my
perspective on Beyond The Zodiacs
themselves even note how similar Beyond
is to Isaac and when Beyond was speaking
on TV ginta stated that it was like
Isaac was speaking directly through him
he also does have at least publicly a
noble-ish goal Beyond's promise with the
expedition was that no matter how many
obstacles stand in the path to our goal
I promise I will remove them age gender
nationality employment race none of it
matters everyone one deserves an equal
opportunity which are all well and good
but it does worry me because this is the
natural methodology we're talking about
and reaching those ideas is probably
going to take us down a path of
bloodthirsty brutality I mean Isaac
natural very much sculpted the world to
his own ideals instituting the hunter
exam to make sure that Only the Strong
cultivated with no respect for the week
whatsoever and that's all going on the
idea that we actually believe Beyond and
this look I don't think I do however
we're really only halfway through this
plan because yes Beyond has orchestrated
everything he needs to make the journey
to the Dark Continent but the actual
Expedition itself is an entirely
different story a story that is heavily
hindered by The Narrative presence of
the hunter Association and the V5
Nations and even the cocking Empire
itself and this is where the current
succession War plays a big role Beyond
netro spent a lot of time in kakin and
with NASA be in particular so there is
no chance that he was unaware of the
succession war and in fact he may have
even encouraged it to take place on the
journey to make sure that he can cause
as much chaos and casualties before the
ship lands thus making his Escape much
easier but this extends to all elements
of the cocky Empire because the
succession war is only happening on the
upper deck below we also have the chaos
spreading fire Morena who was declared
war on her opposing Mafia factions
Marana by the way came into Power
shortly before the Expedition set sail
so that's that's convenient to say the
least I think the Beyond is true to his
name and is a puppet master beyond our
current comprehension he has manipulated
every facet of the kakin Empire sparked
the V5 to act effectively employed the
hunter Association to safely escort him
to the Dark Continent and hey maybe he
even go to the Phantom Trooper board by
making a big public deal about all of
the riches and stuff available and again
this is still only the first half of the
plan who knows what Beyond has in store
once he actually lands on the continent
but the one thing we do know is that
he's in no rush and I guess we'll just
have to wait as long as it takes